trump mise en accusation au lendemain
d'un vote historique
les journaux de partout aux états unis
présente une belle unanimité sur leur
couverture mais dans le pays
les divisions semblent s'être creusé
encore un peu davantage one fraîchement
mise en accusation dans notre chambre
s'est affiché fièrement aux côtés d'un
des deux démocrates dissident qui a voté
contre la procédure singh jeff pachoud
le représentant du new jersey qui vient
de retourner sa veste pour joindre les
rangs républicains comme un pied-de-nez
envoyé par trump à ses accusateurs ce
n'est pas une destitution dit il c'est
un canular un coup monté sous le dôme du
capitole
la chambre devrait passer le relais au
sénat de façon non partisane pour la
suite de la procédure
mais la collaboration s'annonce tout
sauf harmonieuse à le chef de la
majorité républicaine au sénat mitch
mcconnell annonce la couleur
c'est de loin le dossier de destitution
le plus faible et le plus bas qu'est de
l'histoire dit-il
accusant du même coup la chambre d'être
partisane s'il sera appelé à jouer le
rôle de juré dans le procès du président
le sénateur n'essaie même pas de
paraître impartial
avouant travailler de pair avec les
avocats de la maison blanche
alors faute d'échangés des dossiers et
des informations
élus républicains et démocrates
s'échangent des insultes afin d 09
c'est une nouvelle ronde à tort avait
prévu qu'on puisse avoir à faire un
présidence et les radis nancy pelosi
mais il n'avait pas prévu qu'on puisse
avoir en même temps un président et un
scénar scélérat
une tension de plus en plus vives qui
inquiète bien des électeurs de gauche
comme de droite ça n'a jamais été aussi
grave dit marie line il ya trop de haine
[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'il y ait moins de rancoeur
et division à vous nourrit les
polynésiens pense dakar y sont trop
égoïstes les élus au congrès s'apprête à
marquer une pause pour temps des fêtes
vu l'ambiance on pourrait même parler de
trêve mais la saga de la destitution
elle est loin d'être terminée en cette
fin d'année les états unis d'amérique
semble plus désunie que jamais ici jean
françois bélanger a du canada à
washington